Looking back today when we say “Hey, we
bought the UFC for $2 million”
People say “Oh you stole it.”
Um, I’m not sure we did.
I’m not sure it was worth $2 million when
we bought it.
Lorenzo Fertitta is the CEO of the UFC, the
Ultimate Fighting Championship, which is currently
valued at about $4 billion. He owns it along
with his older brother, Frank Fertitta, and
their high school buddy, Dana White.
Growing up in Las Vegas where there were no
professional sports teams,
Lorenzo got to watch a lot of boxing instead.
I was really able to see some of the greatest
fights in boxing history.
Lorenzo’s father started Station Casinos
in the 1970s.
Lorenzo and his brother took the company public in 1993,
when he had just  finished grad school.
So you were a millionaire at 24?
Yes, yes.
Then a few years later, he bumped into his
high school friend, Dana White, at a wedding.
And I think we’ve probably talked to each
other 27 times a day since that day.
So one day, Lorenzo, Frank and Dana all went
down to New Orleans to watch a big UFC fight
Nobody even knew the UFC was in town, that’s
how small as an event that it was at the time.
There was no organization, there was no buzz.
I wanted to go buy like a tshirt or buy a
program, there was nothing there!
And it was really that moment when we were
sitting in our seats at that fight
when me Frank and Dana sitting in a row looked at
each other and said
The UFC wasn’t just unpopular, it was also
banned by almost every state athletic commission
and no cable networks would run the fights.
The owner, Bob Meyrowitz, was looking for
money to keep the business alive.
So I cold-called Bob, it was a very short
conversation. He said he was looking for a million dollars for half the business
So I talked to Frank, and called him back.
And said, “We’re not interested in having partners.
"I’ll offer to buy the whole thing for $2 million.”
But $2 million didn’t get them much more
than a wooden octagon and some fighter contracts.
For the next, I would say five years, it was
a real grind.
The brothers spent $40 million trying to make the sport safer and more palatable.
We want to make it more fan friendly, we want
to get the crowd involved in it.
We had so much push back from networks when
we would go and pitch them and say, “Hey
we’re the UFC and we want to put fights on TV”
How many "No’s" did you get?
Every -- you count the networks! Everybody.
I mean we literally got to the point where
if we could have put in on the Food Network,
we would’ve put it on there.
We knew that just going out and selling fights
wasn’t working so we had to change our strategy
and that’s when we came up with the idea
of The Ultimate Fighter
Since they couldn’t get networks to pick
up regular fights, they made a reality show,
where each episode ended in a fight.
We like to say it was our Trojan horse.
Dana White hosted, and the overall winner
got a contract with the UFC.
The Ultimate Fighter ended up being the turning
point for the company.
But to get it on air, they bankrolled the
entire production themselves and gave it to
Spike TV to run for free.
And because we paid for it, we owned all the
rights. That was the key moment because even
today, one of the real points of value in
the UFC is that we own 100% of everything.
Fine whiskey and good business!
Good business!
Only more good stuff to come
The UFC today has earned itself a spot as
a primetime sport and is watched
by millions around the globe.
The great thing about our sport is that everybody
understands fighting.
And we have the ability, because of that, to really appeal to everybody around the world.
So, you own fighting globally?
Well, we own the UFC,
which is the strongest brand in fighting.